Giulia May: That is weird.
Giulia May: I'm gonna let people out.
Giulia May: Hello, hello! Welcome!
Giulia May: I am going to start in a couple of minutes.
Giulia May: So… Share where you are joining from.
Giulia May: And… Make sure…
Giulia May: You are muted.
Giulia May: So… I'm letting people in… Hello, Kenna! Toti!
Giulia May: I don't know if I pronounced it well… C-S… C-A-O-C?
Giulia May: And then I have Brennan as well, welcome as well.
Giulia May: So, let me put everything in the right environment. I see that my computer is a little bit slow, so I hope it's gonna work out fine.
Giulia May: So, I will wait another 2-3 minutes before I get started.
Giulia May: Let me know where you're from, and since we're a small group at this moment, I'm happy if you unmute yourself. We can have a little chat before we get started, if you feel okay. Hi, Brennan!
Giulia May: Good to meet you.
Brennan Newsom: Nice to meet you.
Giulia May: Where are you from?
Brennan Newsom: Marin County, San Francisco area.
Giulia May: Okay, nice.
Giulia May: And Kenna is from San Diego.
Giulia May: Very, very nice. Are you… okay, there is someone else joining.
Giulia May: Very nice. I'm gonna start in a minute. So, I'm gonna give you, like, a tour through the community. What is important to know is that I'm not a grant expert. I'm your community expert, builder, and architect.
Giulia May: And so, I know very well how the community works, and where to find what.
Giulia May: And I will make sure that after this session, you know exactly where to go next.
Giulia May: So, I assume you're all new to the community, so I'm very happy to welcome you.
Giulia May: And,
Giulia May: As you will see, while we walk around in the community, we just recreated the whole environment. So that means that we have done a lot of design work and a lot of improvements.
Giulia May: And you will see new things showing up in the coming period as well, so that's very nice to know.
Giulia May: And, it's way more, let's say, simple to, follow the steps. So I really try to make it, like, one road that you follow, so that you don't get overwhelmed. It's always a little bit overwhelming to join a community, so…
Giulia May: I hope that this new way of working will make your lives easier.
Giulia May: So, I will get started. So, what I first want to do is show you around a little bit on the more technical stuff, and then we will do a deep dive in what to find where.
Giulia May: So, first of all, here at the top right, you will see, your picture, if you have added a picture.
Giulia May: Yeah, so, yeah, Kenna, I will try to answer your,
Giulia May: your question in a moment. So, yeah. So, at the right side, you will find your settings. So, in the onboarding roadmap, you will see that we're asking three settings, to make sure that you do them.
Giulia May: One is your profile, so that you will… you will find it here, profile. One is notifications, and one is download the app.
Giulia May: So, that's super important.
Giulia May: And, what, the app I find the most important one, because that makes it, even easier to have the community always with you. Then you can join on your iPhone, or whatever.
Giulia May: way you, are able to join us with. And so that makes it really super easy.
Giulia May: Then we have here notifications, so each time you join the community, have a quick look. These are questions, notifications from me or the team members, Matthew, and that in a blink of an eye, you know the latest news. So that's the little bell.
Giulia May: And then here we have, your streaks, so that's just how many days you were, in the community.
Giulia May: Then we have a search button.
Giulia May: You probably will not need it so much, because the community is very organized, but if ever, then here you can search.
Giulia May: And then we move to the left side.
Giulia May: So, first of all, the What's New Today button are the latest posts. So here, you can stay informed on what we have been posting, also what members are posting, their questions, answers, notifications, also some love from the community.
Giulia May: And that's the second thing that I would advise you to have a look at each time you come inside of the community. So, two things. So, the bell, notifications, and then the what's new today.
Giulia May: Then the tab under there, Upcoming Classes, that's our calendar.
Giulia May: We have a lot of classes, and I will show you around in which classes to take when, so there is a process, and not all classes are suited to follow from the beginning.
Giulia May: And the first thing that you also can do if you're looking to go to a class, let's say on Saturday, you can also just click on the date, and then you will see the selection. What are the classes that you can join that day.
Giulia May: People who are very successful in finding grants, they are always people who join a lot of classes, because you learn a lot of stuff all the time.
Giulia May: and also from other people. What type of things they come across, best practices, tips, etc. So, joining classes is super important. If you have the time.
Giulia May: Join as many as you can.
Giulia May: So, then we go to the roadmap, and the roadmap is your roadmap, so that's gonna be your way to find your direction inside of the community. So, after our call here, just go and have a look.
Giulia May: So, the first thing that I would advise you to do today is the practical stuff. So, what I was already saying, complete your profile, adjust your notifications, and download the app.
Giulia May: Here, this will bring you directly to the sections where you do that.
Giulia May: For downloading the app, it's very simple. So you scan with your phone the QR code that is on there, and then you log in with the same password and email address that you used to come inside of the community.
Giulia May: So, 3 small things that are, done quickly.
Giulia May: Then, you will, if you scroll down here, you see all the other steps. Let's move it a little bit like this. I will uncheck them again. You are already in the welcome tour, so that's one thing you can already check off.
Giulia May: I will mute some people… Yeah, okay, we're good.
Giulia May: And, so that's done. And then the number one thing I advise you to do after you have, left this call is start with, creating your call sheets.
Giulia May: So, I will explain you 3 ways that you can create your own call sheets. That's your backbone. That's gonna be your personalized list.
Giulia May: To start contacting people who are, yeah, giving assistance or, yeah, grants.
Giulia May: So, one way is to join a call sheet class, so let's now move…
Giulia May: a little bit to the left, a little bit more. These are your steps. So, you are today already in the welcome tour, and then step 2, 3, and 4 are 3 ways to get your call sheets. So, one is to go to a call sheet class.
Giulia May: I advise you to read through the instructions. This is super handy. What is a call sheet? Why is it important?
Giulia May: how to work with it. If you are unsure, because what I advise you to do is to create one call sheet per problem. So, imagine you need assistance with a car, and then you also need health assistance.
Giulia May: Then you create two call sheets, two separate call sheets.
Giulia May: And if you're unclear, like, how many you need, maybe you need 10. That's perfectly possible. Then you can go over these questions to get clarity for yourself.
Giulia May: The more you're clear, like, these are the things I need, these are things that are a bigger priority, because, yeah, sometimes you have so many things coming your way that it's difficult to know what to tackle first.
Giulia May: But I would, if it's a lot of things, definitely make a priority list as well. Let me tackle the house first.
Giulia May: then I will do my health insurance, and then I will maybe do the car. I just fantasize here, but that you don't get too overwhelmed if it's a lot of things, and that you start to structure.
Giulia May: So here are your instructions. Read that true.
Giulia May: For the classes, there are two, call sheet classes.
Giulia May: One is AI user skills, that's from Roger, so there is one today, so if you want to, you can go to Roger's class today. So, he is our AI specialist. He is going to teach you how to use AI to create your own call sheets.
Giulia May: And he's gonna give you prompts, so it's a little bit more difficult than the Lesko AI app, where we teach you how to do it inside of the community, but still, it's a very, very interesting class. So that's Roger.
Giulia May: Then we have here the AI… the Lesko AI app, the green card, so we have one on Saturday, and that's a workshop where Tony is going to help you to create your own call sheets. He's also going to note down
Giulia May: Your questions, and then create call sheets personalized for you.
Giulia May: So, and then, once that he's finished doing that, he's gonna add them here in the personalized, clause answers. Like, here, this… Amber and Tony are doing that.
Giulia May: So, let me go here, so you can see here, that's Tony.
Giulia May: I want to show you a call sheet.
Giulia May: So, as you can see, that's very elaborate, and that's really specifically created for you, based on what you're looking for, where you live. So, your zip code and state is also important.
Giulia May: And then you will have all the information about the organization.
Giulia May: And that's important as well, because the more you are informed, the better you will come across when you start asking for grants. We also add a call script if you want to call people, etc. So, that is how a call sheet looks.
Giulia May: So, and… That's, the part… so, path number one is go to a call sheet class.
Giulia May: So, if you have time, go to Roger's class today, and otherwise go to,
Giulia May: Tony's class, I would advise you that even if you have already everything you need from one of the three ways that I will explain to you, that you try out all the, different, resources that we have available for you, so that you can really build, the
Giulia May: Some experience on how to use the community, because you will see, you will start with a first series of call sheets, and then afterwards, you will understand certain things better, and then you will want to create new call sheets.
Giulia May: So, the first one here is your AI… the second one here is the AI grant researcher, that's an internal AI.
Giulia May: So, if you want to have a call sheet after this call, this is the fastest way to create yourself a call sheet.
Giulia May: So, you go here, you select the domain, so I was talking about cars, you add your zip code, or you can also add your
Giulia May: State, and then city.
Giulia May: And then you click here, run the research report. This can take a moment. So, just let it run, it will finish. At one point, it can be 2 minutes, it can be 5 minutes, it seems eternity, but it will definitely, lead to a report.
Giulia May: So once it's done, it hops here.
Giulia May: to, the second, page here, and that's the results. So here you will see all the, different,
Giulia May: Hmm.
Sharron Elliott: difficulty walking. I try to not…
Giulia May: Okay, I will mute Sharron.
Giulia May: All the different organizations that DAI found for you, you have an email address, a phone number, and their website.
Giulia May: and also all the information that you also saw on the Excel sheet. So, you can go over them, start contacting them here directly from this page.
Giulia May: But what I would advise you to do is to go one step further and download the results in an Excel or a PDF, so that you can start building a little dossier for each call sheet that you have.
Giulia May: and then you can clear the report and start over. Little disclaimer, you can have little hiccups in the results. AI is not perfect. We're working on it all the time to improve the results. But if something is unclear, or you find something and you have questions.
Giulia May: Join one of the call sheet classes, or…
Giulia May: You ask a question in the questions channel.
Giulia May: And that is the third… the third way to get your call sheets. So here, you can ask questions, you can ask as many questions as you want, as you want, or need.
Giulia May: And so, someone of the team will pick it up and give you an answer. It takes, most of the time, a couple of hours, and then here you see Rose, you have Misty, you have, Tony, answering questions.
Giulia May: And so, they will create a call sheet, so they really take their time to,
Giulia May: sit with your question and formulate a very, well-taught, answer. So, here again, you have an instruction page.
Giulia May: Where we explain how to ask the questions. So, how to post a question, some best practices.
Giulia May: What you need to do each time is also, again, add your zip code, your state, and the question.
Giulia May: Do one post per question, so that the grant coaches really can make a very accurate, not too complicated post specifically for you.
Giulia May: To keep track of what you posted.
Giulia May: Use the little bookmark here.
Giulia May: So, and if you then go to your profile and click on your profile, you will see your bookmarks.
Giulia May: And then you will find all your questions all together in here, which is super handy, because then you can easily follow up
Giulia May: When the grant coaches have answered, but maybe you have another question, and then you have a little library of all the questions you are asking or following up inside of the community.
Giulia May: Of course, you can ask any type of question here, so it doesn't have to be only about, creating a call sheet. So, that's also if you have follow-up questions, or you're in the process of
Giulia May: applying, or you have questions about how to apply, this is also your place to go. So, super important part of the community, that's also why it's in all capitals.
Giulia May: Then, once you have your call sheets.
Giulia May: You are going to do the following things, so you're going to go to an application class.
Giulia May: Again, we have instructions here, best practices on how to apply.
Giulia May: There are several things here, because of course, you will email, you will make calls, but you will also fill in online forms to apply for grants or assistance, and so…
Giulia May: Here, you can read already, some, very interesting information on best practices.
Giulia May: You can download an application checklist, that you… so one per, oh, I thought already, I saw something. So, one, per,
Giulia May: application, so that you can follow up. How far am I in the process? Do I have to call them back?
Giulia May: Do I need to send another email? Maybe they're asking for extra information. So…
Giulia May: It's very nice if you can keep track of what you're doing, because applying alone and then not following up is going to make it less probable that you will have the results that you're hoping for.
Giulia May: So, you can also add a checklist here, so there are some examples, so type the name, check here, new checklist, and then they will be added here, and then you can follow it up inside of the community.
Giulia May: I would advise you to have a dossier. I think it's better.
Giulia May: Then we have here, the 20, phone call rule. So,
Giulia May: sit down for a moment when you have your… and start calling. And so, each time you made a call, just add a little checklist.
Giulia May: Our, statistics have, shown that, each 20 calls, you have,
Giulia May: On average, you will have a good result.
Giulia May: So, that's to keep track of what you have been doing.
Giulia May: Then here, a call script. In the classes, we will also exercise with you, but you can already have a look and make yourself familiar on what to say during a class, and what definitely not to say.
Giulia May: Then,
Giulia May: Here, as well, some smart moves. I will, by the way, start doing some classes myself, where we will roleplay. So it's a lot of fun, and very useful.
Giulia May: Where we can really exercise, and by seeing others, and trying stuff out yourself.
Giulia May: you will get confident, because I think making the phone calls is one of the most scary things for people. And it gets better, of course, but in the meantime, it can really be a bottleneck, and it's super important.
Giulia May: To, apply and have…
Giulia May: Enough, confidence to also… and knowledge on how to make these calls, because it really makes a difference.
Giulia May: So, once you've done that…
Giulia May: you will go to group coaching classes. We have a lot of group coaching classes, so that's basically where we help you with the whole process. Anything that comes up.
Giulia May: So, here you have instructions, again, around, the application.
Giulia May: Yeah, whole process, like, what do you do? How do you keep contact? You will have questions, so hop in at any time in one of the meetings.
Giulia May: We have several types of meetings, so tomorrow we have a meeting that, is about all tips, on pay my, debt and bills. So,
Giulia May: Let me see…
Giulia May: for Kenna, so you could already make a call sheet, specifically for the things that are important for you, and then go to pay my debt and bills tomorrow and, talk with Tony.
Giulia May: So he's very, hands-on on finding financial help… help.
Giulia May: Then, also tomorrow, you have the Grant Clinic, which is also amazing.
Giulia May: that's, the place where you can go and hop in and ask questions almost all day. So, if you're lucky, you even have a one-on-one personal call with one of the grant coaches.
Giulia May: Any question. So then we have the Q&A lives. That's a question hour about
Giulia May: any type of things that come across when you are in the process of looking for grants, finishing grants, when will my money arrive, what is that document, all that kind of stuff. And then open office is more practical stuff.
Giulia May: So, where do I find this or that inside of the community? So, as you can see, lots of meetings here.
Giulia May: And then, last but not least.
Giulia May: Matthew comes live in the community randomly, very often, but he has a fixed moment that you can go to and just ask him questions directly. He is, very knowledgeable about grants, of course, that's his thing.
Giulia May: For many, many decades, and so it's… it's a lot of fun and very interesting to join his classes, and he will, take your, questions one by one, and then,
Giulia May: Formulate what he would do in your case.
Giulia May: So, he's also very good if you're in an urgency situation, to say, like, okay, I now do this first, and then do this, and then do this. So, for urgency situations, he's also very good to, help you out.
Giulia May: Then, for older people who have a business.
Giulia May: a non-profit, I want to do something different in their careers, etc, want to start a business, this is your place to be. So that's Lesko Pro.
Giulia May: So, what you find here are a lot of quick guides and lessons that you can go to, through
Giulia May: This is one of the parts that I'm still building on. You have.
Giulia May: And…
Giulia May: lessons from Matthew, like, he advises… you will see that in the community on several places, that he advises you to make an appointment with a business mentor or coach locally.
Giulia May: Because they know a lot of stuff that will help you, incredibly well. So, for, I think for health, education, for nonprofits, etc, all these different aspects, there are
Giulia May: Plenty of, coaches, available, that will help you for free.
Giulia May: And then, next to that, we have all kinds of quick guides, so…
Giulia May: go over the guides that we have here, and I will show you around. We also have for health, education, and all that kind of stuff.
Giulia May: So… Here, contact these 10 organizations.
Giulia May: So, this is federal. So, if you create a call sheet, or one of the team members creates a call sheet for you, that will be local, information. Not necessarily always, but very often.
Giulia May: All these, quick guides, they are federal help, so that's the two levels you can work on.
Giulia May: You can just go over here and start to contact them immediately.
Giulia May: And all of these lists, you can also download them. So the way how it works is you go over it, you find the ones that you find interesting.
Giulia May: And so, little disclaimer, so, like, here, I haven't updated these yet. The information is there, but it's not downloadable yet, so I'm busy in the process to finishing all that stuff as well.
Giulia May: But you could very easily also, instead of creating a call sheet.
Giulia May: Download the checklists that will work for you, and get started as well.
Giulia May: Then, we have our, business.
Giulia May: Coaching?
Giulia May: So, here, start a business, expand your business about non-profits, etc. So, if that is your area, we have two amazing team members. We have Megan and Amber.
Giulia May: Megan is non-profit, she has a lot of non-profits, Amber is business, she has built her business with grants, so she knows that world in and out.
Giulia May: So, that will be, A very easy way for you to find your way in the right direction.
Giulia May: Let's now move here to some details here. If you missed a class, you can just find them here and watch the replay. We already talked about the personalized class answers.
Giulia May: Then here we have the Quick Guide Library. So, this is like the other one that I showed you some lessons from Matthew.
Giulia May: And then we have the guides that you can download, and Medicare benefits, medical relief, etc. Find whatever it is you need, download the PDF, and start applying where you can.
Giulia May: So, we have big, chunks of information, like bill… bills, debt, homes, and cars, healthcare assistance, taxes and legal help.
Giulia May: Families, seniors, and disabilities, and then veterans.
Giulia May: Then we have safety warnings, not so important at this moment because it doesn't happen so often anymore, but before we had some, impersonators, and then we would post a little post here.
Giulia May: Then here, say hi, a member chat. This is where you can connect with the other members, say hi, etc.
Giulia May: Here is a question from Robina, so we will move that to the questions channel.
Giulia May: Community updates, that's… we start a meeting, a meeting gets canceled, etc. That's what you find here.
Giulia May: Much used latest videos.
Giulia May: And then nationwide grant news.
Giulia May: So that's the big tour through the community.
Giulia May: And now I'm gonna make some time for questions, so anyone who has questions, feel free to unmute yourself. I will read through Kenna's question as well, and see if I can help her first.
Giulia May: I don't see the question anymore.
Giulia May: Let me see…
Kenna Corey: Hi, it's me. Thank you so much. I'm gonna actually, unless you think I should stay on, because I do have a pretty big, busy day, but, I was gonna…
Kenna Corey: Hop off and just get going on my call sheets in order of priority.
Giulia May: Yeah, okay, perfect. And then I would definitely join, the class that I told you about from.
Kenna Corey: Right.
Giulia May: Totally. And then… If.
Kenna Corey: Today… today?
Giulia May: Yeah, that's today. Yeah, in a couple of hours. Okay. Let's see, yeah, so…
Kenna Corey: Oh, it's on the calendar.
Giulia May: already, yeah, your call sheet, and then hop in and say, like, okay, I really need urgent help, and see what he can do. And do as you've done for… in my meeting, put it in the chat immediately so that you catch his attention.
Kenna Corey: Okay, great, good, I'm glad.
Giulia May: Good luck.
Kenna Corey: Oh, this feels so, like, selfish, but… I gotta let her know.
Giulia May: Yay!
Kenna Corey: Excellent.
Giulia May: Okay, we all learned from it. Yeah.
Kenna Corey: No, it sounds like it's the right thing to do, is to put.
Giulia May: numerous.
Kenna Corey: Emergency alert right away, so thank you.
Giulia May: Absolutely. Okay, thank you.
Kenna Corey: Thank you so much, it's, Julie… Juliana?
Giulia May: Giulia. Giulia, yes.
Kenna Corey: Giulia. Is it Italian or Portugal?
Giulia May: Italian, yes.
Kenna Corey: Italian.
Giulia May: Italian, yeah.
Kenna Corey: Italiano. You see, I studied classical Italian cooking.
Giulia May: Oh, fantastic.
Kenna Corey: Culinary school. Yeah, French and Italian, but anyway. I make a wonderful 7-layer lasagna from scratch that's only.
Giulia May: Oh my god.
Kenna Corey: The pasta is, like, paper thin. Anyway, okay, thank you so much! Have a great.
Giulia May: Great day, and we talk soon.
Kenna Corey: Bye.
Giulia May: Kema.
Kenna Corey: By the way.
Giulia May: Bye, bye.
Giulia May: Anyone else who has questions?
Fayrene Koroma: Just don't go out.
Fayrene Koroma: I'm asking you to pay attention to what you're thinking. You are drawing in what you're constantly dwelling on.
Fayrene Koroma: Your thoughts are running your mind.
Fayrene Koroma: What do you mean?
Giulia May: Fair enough…
Fayrene Koroma: Fayrene. The name is Fayrene. Fayrene, you can call me Fay. Hi, you can call me Fay.
Giulia May: Faye, hi. Can you…
Fayrene Koroma: Hi, how are you?
Giulia May: Tell a little bit your question.
Fayrene Koroma: Oh, I don't have a question, I'm just new, and I don't know what this is yet, so…
Giulia May: Okay.
Giulia May: Yeah, you…
Fayrene Koroma: I'm trying to find out what it is. I just came because I just saw the email. He sends emails every day, just about, so…
Giulia May: Yeah.
Fayrene Koroma: I just happened to see the email that y'all were having a welcome seminar today. I guess it's to, help me go over the website that y'all have.
Giulia May: That's correct, but there is a class tomorrow as well, and so, in a nutshell, so you will find… so, it's a little repetition for the rest of you guys as well.
Giulia May: We have here a roadmap that is gonna show all the steps you need to do. So, basically, you just follow the steps. And so, it's one by one. There are 3 ways to make a call sheet.
Giulia May: And that's after you've done the welcome meeting, that's your number one thing to do. So, go to a call sheet class.
Giulia May: Try out the AI Grant Researcher, so that's also, our tool to make grants, call sheets.
Giulia May: And then, the last one is you can also ask your question inside of the questions channel, but if you remember one thing of this class, is that your next thing to do is make yourself your call sheets.
Giulia May: You have, not for all roadmap steps, but most of them, you also have instructions, so read them too.
Giulia May: Once you have your call sheets, go to an application class and read the instructions.
Giulia May: So that you know how to apply.
Giulia May: And then go to group coaching. So that's, in a nutshell, what we have been talking about today.
Giulia May: So, and you can join this class again tomorrow, so we have one every day. I know it's early in the morning, but, it's still… yeah, I'm telling the same story each time, but it's very useful.
Giulia May: To get started.
Giulia May: And, yeah, it's… it's not… I will not say it's simple, but in a way it is. So, now your next thing you do is create one or more call sheets. So, one call sheet for each problem you want to solve.
Fayrene Koroma: Okay, beautiful.
Julann  (5-1-2026 1004 AM): Put it on you?
Giulia May: Okay, I mean, why not?
Julann  (5-1-2026 1004 AM): Yeah, you ate it.
Giulia May: What about?
Julann  (5-1-2026 1004 AM): That's see.
Julann  (5-1-2026 1004 AM): Okay, I'm sorry.
Giulia May: Thank you, Faye!
Julann  (5-1-2026 1004 AM): Mmm.
Fayrene Koroma: Yeah, okay, so I have a question. Y'all have anybody that helps you with social media, like…
Julann  (5-1-2026 1004 AM): You know.
Fayrene Koroma: videos.
Julann  (5-1-2026 1004 AM): The whole thing, you wanna repeat the whole thing?
Giulia May: I'm sorry.
Giulia May: Julann?
Julann  (5-1-2026 1004 AM): I'm behind you.
Giulia May: I'm not sure who is making… let me see… Adam!
Fayrene Koroma: I had a… I had a question. I just… Okay.
Giulia May: Yeah.
Fayrene Koroma: Okay. Alright, do you have anybody in the community that actually helps you with social media, like helping you do videos, so you can put them on social media, like YouTube, things like that? That's what I need help.
Giulia May: No, not really, no. We're really hyper-focused on grants, so we… what I advise you to do
Giulia May: If you're looking at, putting yourself out there on social
Giulia May: is go to YouTube. There are so many amazing creators, and so many things you can learn directly on YouTube.
Giulia May: I think even for me, like, I'm doing a lot of vibe coding and super complicated things, and I still go to YouTube. And what you look for is, you will see in each domain, if you search for something, is that you will see people who are very popular.
Giulia May: And, also videos that have high amount of viewers, and that's a big indication, that it.
Fayrene Koroma: You're good.
Giulia May: Oops.
Giulia May: And you watch, and then you learn the environment, and after a while, you will find people that really fit your purpose. And the amount of information… or you ask AI, like, what are the top 3 creators? I want to do this.
Giulia May: I want to learn ABCD, who are the best creators on YouTube, and then you will get an answer, and you start there.
Fayrene Koroma: Okay.
Giulia May: That's what.
Fayrene Koroma: So go to AI, go to AI and ask, who… who are the top 3 creators on YouTube?
Fayrene Koroma: Is that what you just said?
Giulia May: You explain very well what you want to do, and what you want to learn?
Fayrene Koroma: Videos, like, at my office, just… I am a professional counselor, so I just want the Richmond, Virginia area to get to know me, because I'm from Northern Virginia. I've only been here a few years.
Giulia May: Very smart move.
Fayrene Koroma: So I'm trying to get my… the word out, mainly in Richmond, Virginia, that I do the professional counseling. So I'm gonna go to AI and put that in, and see what comes up.
Giulia May: Yeah.
Fayrene Koroma: Yeah, suggest. Okay.
Fayrene Koroma: Okay, thank you so much.
Giulia May: Fantastic. Anyone else?
Giulia May: Who has questions?
Giulia May: I'm looking at the.
Robina Steele: I do. I have questions. So, I've been on the platform for a little while. Hi, I'm Robina, sorry. Okay.
Giulia May: Kenna.
Robina Steele: Hi. I've been on this platform for a while, but I haven't really had much luck, and I've had days where… I mean, I've had times where I've, like, been diligent about it, and I've been on every day, like, you know, trying to do the classes and stuff like that, but I just haven't had much luck.
Robina Steele: And I ask questions, I put questions in and everything. I do find this, this platform very informative, but I do want to learn more, and I want to actually win some grants, so I'm just trying to get better at it, but right now, my issue is, so I'm a… I'm married, but I have grandkids, and
Robina Steele: and I'm helping them, and so right now, they're displaced, and, so I'm really trying to, like, find house… a grant that I can… that can help me with housing, so… so I can help house them.
Giulia May: Yeah, okay. Have you been to one of the classes, in the group coaching already?
Robina Steele: I have.
Giulia May: Yeah, and who have you been talking to?
Robina Steele: I can't not think of her name,
Giulia May: maybe Amber, Megan…
Robina Steele: I know I've been to some of Amber's, I've been to a couple of her classes. There was another young lady, I can't think of her name right off, she's even messaged me before, and I tried to… I followed the steps that she told me, but I just really haven't had much luck. Yeah.
Giulia May: I… what I would do, if I were you, is go back, to, I would say, or Tony's class, around, how to, in the group coaching classes.
Robina Steele: tiny.
Robina Steele: Yeah. Maka.
Giulia May: And also, tomorrow, the drop… the grant clinic here, the drop-in, clinic is open all day, so… Okay. And there you have Amber, who is going to be there, and you
Giulia May: might also ask her the same question. Unfortunately, I am not a grant expert, so I can explain how the community works, who is very good at certain things, and what are logical next steps, but I cannot go into details, because I will say stupid things.
Robina Steele: Oh, no, that's fine. You've already, like, kind of, you know.
Robina Steele: I will ask Tony. I think I've talked to… like I said, I know I've talked to Amber before, and there was another lady that I've talked to, too. I can't think of her. She runs some classes. And she sent me some stuff, and I did exactly what she told me to do, but I just, like, literally haven't had luck. I'm not fearful of calling people or anything, because Matthew tells you to do that, too, so I'm not fearful. I will call people. But you keep getting the same responses.
Robina Steele: So it's like, come to us, what am I doing? What can I do now?
Giulia May: Yeah, so what would be interesting is that you go into the class and you come with examples. You say, okay, that's the list I got from you.
Robina Steele: Okay.
Giulia May: I have a call, and I have no result. How can we improve my call list, so that… Okay. Yeah, then they can be more precise in helping you out.
Robina Steele: I will do that, because I have a list. So, I most definitely will do that. Thank you. So, you said… what time is, you said today, is there a class today, you said, for Tony? Or is that tomorrow?
Giulia May: Yeah, no, today, let me have a look that I don't say anything stupid. But if I look for today.
Giulia May: So, we still have, Tony's Class AI User Skills. So, and be careful, I'm in CST, I'm in Brussels, Europe, so I have weird hours. So, that would be your 4pm EST.
Robina Steele: Okay.
Giulia May: So, yeah.
Giulia May: that's the class we're in, and then Amber has a business class.
Giulia May: But, yeah. You… because, Tony, might be able to create a new report for you. Yeah.
Robina Steele: Oh, okay.
Giulia May: Yeah? Okay, that's great.
Robina Steele: Thank you, thank you so much.
Giulia May: And I hope you find a solution for the grandkids very soon.
Robina Steele: I appreciate that.
Giulia May: Yeah.
Giulia May: Anyone else?
Giulia May: Who has a question?
Giulia May: If we don't have any more questions, then I will finish the meeting.
Giulia May: So, last time, next thing to do is create your call sheet. There is a class from Tony a little bit later, so if you have a call sheet created already with the AI tool.
Giulia May: You can go to his class, or just, ask him to help you out to create one, so that would be your next step.
Giulia May: And I would say, say hi to Tony from me, and
Giulia May: Good luck, everyone, and hope to see you again in one of the meetings.
Giulia May: Take good care!
Giulia May: Bye, everyone!
Fayrene Koroma: Thank you.
Robina Steele: Bye-bye. Have a good day.
Fayrene Koroma: Have a good day.
Giulia May: Bye, you too.
Fayrene Koroma: Send me a ticket to Brussels.
Giulia May: Yeah, that would be amazing. I would love that.
Fayrene Koroma: How far… how far are you from London? I'm going to London next year for a book, a book signing.
Giulia May: Not far at all.
Fayrene Koroma: How far? Like, I've been to Brussels once before. I think that we were in… I think we were in Brussels, and then we drove to Paris.
Giulia May: Yeah, yes.
Fayrene Koroma: driving this to Paris, right? Yeah. So, okay, so then do you… how far is it, then, from London?
Giulia May: Where…
Fayrene Koroma: book fair.
Fayrene Koroma: In March. I wrote… I'm an author, I wrote a book, so the book is selling now in London, so I'm now ready to go over there to do a book signing. Oh, congratulations.
Giulia May: Congratulations.
Fayrene Koroma: It took a long time. I wrote the book in 2013. It was really around 2016, somewhere around there, when my publishing company took it there, and then people start buying it. So I waited until I have about at least 20 to 30 people who have bought it, and then now I'm ready to go over there. So it's gonna be March.
Giulia May: Okay.
Fayrene Koroma: 2027. So, if I'm in London, is there… can I drive… is it in driving distance to Brussels, or I have to take a train?
Giulia May: The train is so easy, because you have a high-speed train between Brussels and London. It's about 2 hours.
Fayrene Koroma: 2 hours.
Giulia May: Soon, yeah.
Giulia May: Yeah, it's super fuss, yeah.
Fayrene Koroma: Yeah, okay, so I haven't been there just once, just driving through. We picked up… we took a flight, and it… it was… the flight was to Brussels, and then we took a… we drove to Paris. Yeah. I remember that. Anyway, so thank you very much, and I'll try to…
Giulia May: Very quick as well.
Fayrene Koroma: Call sheet. What is this call sheet? What is that? I don't know what that is. When you say call sheet, what is that?
Fayrene Koroma: It's true.
Giulia May: There's a list?
Giulia May: It's a list with all the addresses for you to call, specifically tailored to your question and your state's city.
Fayrene Koroma: Okay, so when I go on the website here for, Les Go Help, I'm gonna look under call sheet, I should be able to click that call sheet.
Giulia May: So, here…
Fayrene Koroma: Okay.
Giulia May: You can… you can do here AI Grant Researcher, and you.
Fayrene Koroma: You can…
Giulia May: Create a call sheet from here.
Fayrene Koroma: What I would…
Giulia May: would do is I would go to the AI User Skill class from Tony.
Giulia May: different publisher.
Fayrene Koroma: Okay, when is that gonna be? It's gonna be today, but at what time, the AI YouTube skills?
Giulia May: It's 4PM EST.
Fayrene Koroma: Okay, 4PM today, okay.
Giulia May: Yep.
Fayrene Koroma: Yeah, I have a… I'm supposed to have a meeting at that time, so when is the next one, the next AI User Skills class? When is the next one?
Giulia May: The next one, to create call sheets is on Saturday.
Fayrene Koroma: Okay, Saturday at what time?
Giulia May: Let me see… oh no, it's gonna be Friday at…
Fayrene Koroma: Friday, that'd be better.
Fayrene Koroma: I could do Friday.
Giulia May: I need to recalculate, because that would be… at, I think 7.
Fayrene Koroma: Oh, 7 p.m. Friday, and that's… the name of the class is AI User Skills, is that the one?
Giulia May: Let's, let's go AI app.
Fayrene Koroma: Lesko.
Giulia May: green one. Yeah.
Fayrene Koroma: AI app, and that's the class that I… they'll teach me how to do a call sheet, right?
Giulia May: Yeah, create.
Fayrene Koroma: Okay, so that's the one I need to come to. Let's go… yeah, and that's Friday at what time?
Giulia May: I think 7, but open it inside of the community and make sure, because, yeah, I have to…
Fayrene Koroma: Go check it now, because that's the one I need to do, because like I said, you know, you spend money, but you don't even know what you're spending your money for, so I was like, let me go to a class so I know what I spent my money on. So I'm learning slowly, you know, I just joined maybe a couple of weeks ago, so I'm just learning. So what I'll do is I'll put that on my schedule for 7pm on Friday so I can learn about the call sheet. That's the next step.
Giulia May: Yeah, that's…
Fayrene Koroma: Thanks so much.
Fayrene Koroma: Thank you so much.
Giulia May: Yeah, of course.
Fayrene Koroma: becoming so much clearer, and I'm so happy that I joined this, because I'm really learning a lot. So, thank you so much.
Giulia May: Thank you.
Fayrene Koroma: I've been to, like, about two, two of Amber's classes, because she talks a lot about how to apply for grants, and I know I applied for one of the grants that she had on there, supposed to do the, announcement on August 31, one of them. Yeah. So then, the next thing is that I want to learn about the call sheet. That's what I need to do next.
Giulia May: Yeah, absolutely.
Fayrene Koroma: Oh, good, thank you.
Giulia May: Thank you.
Fayrene Koroma: Thank you. Sharron. Have a good day.
Giulia May: have… You too. Sharon, you had a question?
Sharron Elliott: Yes, good morning. Actually, I was going to tell Faya, I believe that's how you pronounce her name…
Fayrene Koroma: Faye, just call me Faye. Just call me Faye. Just Faye.
Sharron Elliott: Sharon, and I want to say that tomorrow they have the clinic as well. The clinic is coming up.
Fayrene Koroma: What time is that tomorrow, though? What time is the clinic tomorrow?
Sharron Elliott: It's all good.
Giulia May: day.
Fayrene Koroma: All day. So that means that it keeps rolling, it's a rolling clinic? Like, it starts, and then for an hour, then it goes again? What do you mean, it's all day? Because… So, it's… specific hours?
Giulia May: Here, Grand Clinic…
Fayrene Koroma: Oh, great.
Giulia May: It starts in the morning, and it ends in the evening.
Fayrene Koroma: Oh, okay, so you just pop one whenever you're available tomorrow.
Fayrene Koroma: So, I can do that tomorrow afternoon, like, say maybe about 1 o'clock.
Giulia May: Correct. Very good tip.
Fayrene Koroma: So just click on that. So I'll be out and about, so I probably will click on it on my cell phone, so whenever I click on it, I can just join in whatever time, the grant clinic.
Giulia May: Yeah, correct.
Fayrene Koroma: Tomorrow, yes, Thursday.
Fayrene Koroma: Yeah, thank you. I got Thursday and Friday, great, great, great. So that might have been Friday, I should be a pro at this. I'm really excited, very excited about it. I just didn't know when I was joining, so everything's starting to get clearer, and you guys present the classes are excellent. Like, I've taken a couple of Amber's classes, just excellent material, so I'm really excited, so I will…
Fayrene Koroma: Tune back in tomorrow,
Fayrene Koroma: sometime during the day, have an appointment, but I can get on probably about 1 o'clock, and then I'll tune in again on Friday around 7.
Giulia May: February.
Giulia May: That's a good idea.
Fayrene Koroma: what I'm doing, yeah, by that time I should know what I'm doing, so thank you so much.
Giulia May: Okay, great.
Giulia May: Very well. Anyone else who wants to ask something?
Giulia May: So… Hi, Persephone! How are you doing today?
Giulia May: So…
Giulia May: If there are no more questions, I will, call it a day for, this meeting. I will be live tomorrow again, same time, so you can join again if you want to.
Sharron Elliott: Outstanding.
Giulia May: Okay, thank you so much!
Fayrene Koroma: Bye-bye!
Giulia May: Hi, everyone! Take care!
Giulia May: Bye.
Sharron Elliott: Right.
Giulia May: Bye, everyone!